[Musik]
danke für die vielen kommentare sind die
viele positive kommentare wir sind dabei
die ganze kritik wo ist deine kommentare
hat sich ja es stimmt und remo christ
und darum
schöne studie und dem stadtdirektor
stelle gespart
kommentare natalie schrieb zum beispiel
eine solche aufklärung ich meine der
aktualisierung des wissens aus den 80er
und 90er jahren über haifa war längst
überfällig eltern danke für den
kommentar der messe koala schreibt eine
echt tolle reportage und sehr nette
menschen das gericht setzte heute ist er
ja grundsätzlich bin mega überrascht wie
viele positive kommentare sind und
gespürt haben dass blüten immer angst
vor dem thema also jetzt kann man
darüber schweizer sich ja diskussion ist
eröffnet und es ist wunderschön zum ziel
dass das lied offensichtlich bewegt und
eine positive wichtig aber du hast sogar
auch kommentar über coco lied wurde von
peter kratz schön also offensichtlich
ist an stücken immer gewusst dass das
schätzen würde ein videokommentar
ischinger chor wurde anna bereiten remo
und oder michel medikamenten engpässe
und steigenden krankenkassenprämien
sowie
ehrlichkeit mut und zwar willig die
sunny gut funktioniert hat ihr euch
heitz anderen gehört dass es irgendwie
ihr könnt die invesco oder dass ich mir
bitte krankenkasse sich gegen die
großartige bis wir verändern dass es
plötzlich wirklich schwierig werde zum
finanziell bezirk war schwierig werden
aber ja so langsam maße so blickt die
sich manchmal einfach keine sorge machen
und ich hoffe natürlich dass es ungefähr
so beliebt sind sind viele kommentare
zum thema prävention einige
angeschriebene dass mir der körpertausch
häufig auf die leichte schulter nehmen
oder das ganze nicht so ernst aber zum
beispiel schrieb totti us-dollar sind
sonst schockierend finde ich die
tatsache dass der film sowohl auf
individuelle wie auch
gesamtgesellschaftliche ebene die folgen
einer hiv-infektion entweder verharmlost
oder
gar nicht erst thematisiert er beschrieb
pitt money schriebt interessanter
beitrag finde es aber wichtig die
ansteckung zu fahren nicht kleinzureden
im sinne von nötig anstieg ist es kein
problem gibt ja ein medikament dafür ich
glaube einfach
größte präventions- themen wurde im film
angesprochen wurde sind ich stieg was
also ich glaube es kommt über etwas das
du hast etwas das mich kämpfen hat und
frau aus krakau hat ja natürlich also es
ist es soll alles andere als ein daumen
hoch für geschätzte sechs oder soll bis
sie es ist schwere krankheit ist
frankreich wo meist leben lang noch
beschäftigt das ist die krankheit die
medikamente und gier sind die hosted
sehr viel und vor dem herrlich überhaupt
nicht wieso man auf die leichte schulter
nehmen irgendeiner muss sehr viel stoff
passen und schon teilstücke walfang wenn
medikamente richtig macht und sich
kontrolliert regelmäßig haben wir
eigentlich immer mehr stecken und das
ist mega wichtig zum winter hat ganz
viel über falsche bilder im kopf und
wenn man die wissenschaftliche fakten
alten ich relativ schnell war klar dass
man einfach nur steckbare am wichtigsten
sei aber dass man das über nicht
reporters gemacht haben mittlerweile
irgendwie die präventionsmaßnahme klärte
im gegenteil am schluss stand es bleibt
wichtig dass man sich schützt einer für
den schutz ist therapie wie sie die
rehmer macht dass ich einfach dass
schutz vor hiv positiver gegenüber
andere das kondom bleibt wichtig es gibt
eine andere möglichkeit zum beispiel
prep das haben jetzt nicht erwähnt dass
ich das medikament thomas präventions-
medikamenten konnte und wenn man das
nimmt kann man sich mit steckte also wo
wo es zum zum beispiel auch in coco
kreise
wird das empfohlen also sagen ich zum
beispiel in acht lasse es ist aber sehr
kontrovers will man natürlich dann
vielleicht eher als kondom verzichtet
und dann anträge reichen da kann sich
definitiv kontrovers will
nur dass man sich eine mentale stärke
bedeutet nicht dass im kreis schlecht
frankreich und darum muss man sehr viel
stoff passen also bitte medikament das
ist ein guter schutz aber schlussendlich
heißt das nicht dass man bei dem musik
achtet was man nicht am technisch
natürlich auch immer noch sehr wichtig
und wir vorstellen test ist das
überhaupt will ist gott ist dann steht
nein ich glaube es nötig hat zahlt für
mit estos marica 80 franken zahlt im
checkpoint
niedrig kommentarische innerkofler das
quattro eine kritik an den reporter dass
du sagst junkie also die person aufzählt
die heute noch von steht muss lesen hier
wäre es wünschenswert wenn du junkie mit
gänsen füßen gesagt hättest um weitere
stigmas von drogenabhängigen menschen zu
verhindern da muss ich die rechte der
squad oder muss ich mich selber der
eigene organe ich habe jetzt gelernt das
wort junkie hund von st für abfall und
ist diskriminierend und
bettag mark seit und das ist nicht
richtig dafür man für die hippies jetzt
kommt ein ganz wichtiger kommentar für
die grabinschrift
es heißt infiziert und nicht investiert
sagte
katrin zeigt auf das netbook schweizer
deutschland bucht das ab jetzt nehme ich
infiziert
ein videokommentar ishiaku branding 111
ich finde es sei tragisch dass man so
über haifa lachen kann nach dem motto du
bist infiziert scheißegal und im
tablette und du lebst sogar länger als
andere so ein schwachsinn es ist ein
chemie cocktail langfristig immer
nebenwirkungen hat gut als rettung aber
sicher nicht intelligent so leichtsinnig
damit umzugehen das ist mega frontaler
angriff wohl überhaupt kein verständnis
hat dafür aber dann haben wir vorwärts
dieser sie leichtsinnig mit dem thema
umgang war aber irgendwie aus der luft
trifft will er weiß nicht wann ihr für
den prozess zurück macht wenn du hiv
bekundet wenn du die infizierte schmidt
der mit dem virus das ist sehr schön
riesiger schock und typisch sehr schmal
traurig und muss ist eine lehrstelle
damaligen partner rechnen hätte vor
schluss gemacht und das sind sache wo
extrem viel wo extrem viel emotionen
auslösen und es ist einfach falsch zum
futter das ist auf die leichte schulter
nehme auch hübner wenn ich neue leute
treffen
das ist immer ein thema am anfang und so
abartig ich erstmal total aus der luft
liegt und es wurden einfach sehr sehr
unfair so sei das thema chemie cocktail
es stimmt dass die medikament wo man
nicht nur toni werden aber wirkliche
sind alle sind allerdings sind die
zusagen noch einigermaßen gesund sind
praktisch nicht spürbare und führt nach
total als normales leben also auch
irgendwie wieder sowie panikmache in der
luft und die nicht verständnis für
solche politiker von uid wo erst mal
wurde ich nie es wort mit dem er
infizierte gewechselten und zweitens
wahrscheinlich sehr dünne faktenlage
heinz um so die politiker zu machen man
muss ja die arbeit wird während
differenzieren also die in arbeit wirkt
über du hast vor dem medien die letzte
tour jahr ist ganz andere ist auch vor
dem michele wo ihre sichere anderes
regime wo medikamente
situiert 20 jahre hat also sieht voß der
erste stuhl
phototherapie hat sie dir und sie hat
mir antwortet auf die frage oder oft auf
den kommentar in der mail und spricht
das vor lasse als langzeit überlebende
ist es mir wichtig auch wenn es sich
heute gut mit hiv leben lässt klar
festzustellen es ist und bleibt kein
zuckerschlecken auch als privilegierte
patientin mit zugang zu erfolgreichen
therapie muss nicht nur mit
zwischenmenschlichen und aktuellen
diskriminierungen und konflikten
umgegangen werden sondern auch mit
langzeit schädigungen sowohl durch die
infektion als auch durch die
medikamenten und die lang sieht aber
wirklich wo sie hat sind schattige von
binder klebt und sie hat mehrfach
europäische marke und zweifall und hat
osteoporose das ist vermindert die
knochendichte und man aber bezüglich
chemiecocktail legt sich nicht weil
wirklich noch weiß medikaments nützen da
war leichtsinnig genau die maxi
kommentar ich ihnen herzlich
clark an aids und hiv dort küssen
übertragen werden ihr verharmlost hier
gefährlich kleine verletzungen oder
zahnfleischbluten erhöhen das risiko
einer ansteckung
ich weiß es eine präventionskampagne
ronny
recherchiert haben das küssen und
übertragbar ist zumindest sieht eine
ganze kampagne etwas aber normalen nach
klasse und für die deutsche aids hilfe
schreibt selbst bei langen und
ausgiebigen knutschen und intensiven
zungenküssen ist eine hiv übertragung
ausgeschlossen das liegt daran dass
speicher nicht infektiös ist selbst bei
zahnfleischbluten wird möglich ist
infiziertes blut durch speichel so sehr
verdient dass es nicht zu einer
ansteckung kommen kann somit kann man
zum letzten kommentar von dem imam ihn
nur ein schöner kommentar zum schluss wo
mich sehr berührt hat großartig die
fortschritte in der forschung freut mich
sehr für die beiden und alle anderen die
es betrifft meine eltern hatten dieses
glück 1991 und 1995 leider noch nicht
und sie beide daran verstorben als ich
noch ein schulkind war umso schöner zu
sehen dass man heute gut damit leben
alles liebe euch beiden uns mögen die
vorteile irgendwann verstummen erste
schöne schluss wenn die weitere fahrt
zum thema oder reagierte könnte es auch
etwas in dem video der kommentator ich
werde mir die dialoge und durch die rega
und vergessenen der kanal zu abonnieren